we're not showing wall-to-wall video of
that caravan itself because whatever you
think about the people in it there's no
evidence they are as the administration
is suggesting some kind of invading army
infiltrated potentially by terrorists
looming on the US border the idea that
we are under threat from these poor
desperate people is just absurd I mean
it is just the bottom of the barrel
politics that he's engaged in it
well those dismissals come as new
reports tonight that yet another Caravan
is forming originating in Honduras as
for the government's response
yesterday's Washington Post reporting
there is a sinking feeling among the
department of homeland security
officials that more caravans are yet to
come and that they will only get larger
but to the left this is nothing more
than a scare tactic maybe Trump is even
forming the caravans himself well at
least according to Morning Joe this
Caravan hmm that Donald Trump keeps
talking about that Fox News keeps
talking about the people on the right
keep talking about as some last-ditch
desperate sad pathetic effort to again
use white people non-white people to try
to scare white people into voting for
Republicans it's over a thousand miles
away by the way what there are over a
thousand miles away and they what wait
there's some babies wait they may not be
here until December wait what what oh my
god that's so not funny
joining us with her thoughts is Ann
Coulter author of the new book
resistance is futile how the Trump
aiding left lost its collective mind and
do you think the left here think that we
just shouldn't be concerned at all about
a massive Caravan barreling toward the
US border do they think it's just a
political hype job from the president or
a combo well they definitely want these
caravans to keep coming they've been
coming a long time that that attack on
white people being and that's what we're
afraid of
for one thing this country is barely
majority white anymore we're still a
country though and all of the people in
this country
again barely majority-white I don't know
how much longer they can keep up this
taunting of who Sookie or Dwight people
we're allowed to decide who comes in and
who doesn't come in oh and the fact that
CNN says well we're not covering it
we're not like covering it wall-to-wall
right i right mad I I imagine I imagine
that's in part a political calculation
by some of the other networks because I
think most people see this and including
Hispanic Americans African Americans and
they see gosh how is this fair when all
these other people have to you know
apply and spend money applying and do it
the right way I think it comes down just
a basic sense of fairness not that we're
not compassionate right and I mean also
fairness I'm here Trump saying this you
know fairness to immigrants who do it
the legal way which is very difficult
but how about fairness to Americans this
illegal alien child molester is costing
Utah taxpayers more than a million
dollars for his cancer treatments more
than a million dollars I'm sorry that's
money that should be going to an
American cancer patient he's sitting in
jail and getting full free cancer
treatment this obsession with not just
the liberal media but we really see it
with a liberal media with everything
going on far far far away from us we
have troops all over the world we have
troops in Afghanistan troops in Syria
we're not paying attention to what's
happening right on our border it's it's
as if France in the late 30s became
obsessed with with a with a war in
Central America and that's all we talk
about and no no we're not going to
report on what's happening right next
door in Germany no one mentioned that no
this is our problem what's happening at
the border there's a reason that
Americans maybe maybe Trump and his
administration don't understand why the
chance during his spectacular miraculous
campaign was build the wall but the
people making that chance had a reason
for it and that's oh we don't have to go
through this fighting over a caravan
every two months and you know they slip
through and oh well what can we do I
mean there's so many things the
president can do besides build the wall
himself he is the commander-in-chief for
building walls all over the world just
not to protect our country
the military can't really doing do
anything standing on our side of the
border what are they gonna do shoot the
invaders but they could invade they
could go in ten yards into Mexico we
didn't ask for a rocks approval to go in
we didn't ask for Afghanistan's approval
to go in this is actually nothing other
than you know sitting on oil
most of these Middle Eastern countries
they're they're not going to kill
Americans lots of Americans are being
killed killed in drunk-driving accidents
and killed or molested and not to
mention sucking up all these benefits
like a child molester in Utah and none
of that none of the media outlets who
are burning and emoting over the caravan
embedded reporters do many stories about
those who've been victimized by illegal
aliens in the United States were
criminals and I want to play something
for you and I'm sorry to torch you on a
Friday night
but John Kasich John Kasich was out
there this week and he's just of course
mister never Trump but he's outraged
that people wouldn't respond in a more
compassionate way here let's watch it
could easily have been all of us that
we're in the caravan that we're marching
north trying to save our families and
save our children we've got to start
putting ourselves in the shoes of other
people let us reach out to those who
have less and let's stop putting up
walls around ourselves and not
understanding the plight the trouble and
the problems of others it is not right
and the Lord doesn't want it well the
Lord didn't want him as the GOP nominee
either it's a shock and that he didn't
win the nomination by putting the
concerns of other nations before you
know the middle-class blue-collar
workers in the United States yes that's
just what I was thinking as you were
playing now what a surprise that guy
didn't win look Americans are very
compassionate but our compassion has
worn thin this is like a con man or a
gypsy you know appealing to us oh the
poor children we have our own poor
people this is we need to protect our
own country our own citizens which sorry
Joe Scarborough and it were barely
hanging on to majority white so stop
saying this is white
against against the the brown throngs
that isn't what's going on we we have an
obligation to our own citizens who have
really given at the office back room to
me long these people who are obsessed
with color the most racially obsessed
people in the United States are coming
from the left today because we're
fighting yet the American people of
every background every religion every
ethnicity the American citizenry and I
want to play one quick thing for you the
truth sometimes slips out a member of
the invading horde as a friend of mine
here likes to say admitted we do have
some undesirables in the crowd let's
watch criminals is everywhere okay
it's criminal Singh here I mean it is
but he said but most of them
all right criminal okay at least he gave
us that I'll give him that yeah I mean
of course there are criminals in this
crew but even if there were no criminals
there they are a mass of very very poor
people what is a country other than the
people who live in it I mean there are
there are what seven billion people in
the world I'm sure they'd all love to
come too and they keep taking polls in
other countries lots of them would like
to move to the greatest superpower in
the world the greatest country in the
world unless we give it away through
immigration with a massive welfare state
we have to draw the line someplace so
most Americans were saying how about
right now
about twenty years ago we finally had a
president who was saying how about we
put an end to it now but he doesn't seem
to be following through on it I know
he's got oh he's got oh he said he's not
gay he's gonna close the border if
necessary to these migrants and
obviously 800 troops but they you know
they're basically in a facilitator
helping mode but and it's always great
to have it's it's always great to have
idea thanks thanks so much